We just used one method for factoring this polynomial right here, 5x squared
minus 28x minus 12. And because I know that factoring polynomials that don't
have leading coefficient of 1 is a little bit tricky, I want to take a second to
go more in-depth into the logic of figuring out what numbers belong in our
linear factors. Saying that a polynomial like this one, of degree 2, is
factorable, it means that we can write it in this form. As two linear factors,
or factors with an x to the first power in them, multiplied together. And the
general form of a linear factor is just like this. You have some coefficient
times x plus some constant term, what we've been talking about is how to figure
out what numbers belong here. Now, of course, one way to do this is to factor by
grouping like we have been that entailed expanding this middle term into two
terms that added together to equal it and then grouping pairs of terms together,
so considering this first pair as a chunk, and the second pair as a separate
chunk, and pulling the greatest common factor that we can out of either those
pairs. This is why we call this factoring by grouping, because we're grouping
these terms and grouping these terms. We can use a slightly different kind of
logic though, to get to the same answer. If we've already written out the form
that we want the equation to end up in, we can look directly at what we might
want from these different coefficients and constant terms based on what we start
out with. We know that the way we end up with this x squared term here is by
multiplying the term with an x to the first power from each binomial in it. So,
that means that whatever the coefficient is here, multiplied by this
coefficient, must equal 5. We can write out all the different factors of 5, we
can either have 1 times 5 or we could have negative 1 times negative 5. Now,
another thing we know is that the two constant terms multiplied together, equal
the constant term in the original expression. So, we can think about the factors
of negative 12 as well. There are a ton of different ones here. I guess I will
write them all out though just for your pleasure, and voila, there we go. I hope
I didn't miss any. Now we know that the way we get this negative 28, the
coefficient of the middle term here, is by multiplying whatever this number is
times this number. And then, adding that to this number times this number. That
means, we are going to have either 5 times some number plus 1 times some number
equals to negative 28 or for the other pair over here, negative 5 times
something minus 1 times something equals negative 28. Now, since I rather have
two positive coefficients for x having the two negative ones, let's just select
to use 5 equals 1 time 5. This makes our job a lot easier because that only
leaves 1 combination of factors over here that we can plug in. You just have to
figure out which one it is. And, of course, as we already saw in the previous
quiz, we know that this has to be negative 6 and this has to be positive 2. I
can fill in the coefficients in front of the x's, and then since I know that the
two outer terms multiply when we're trying to find this middle coefficient, and
the negative 6 goes in this slot, and the 2 goes in this slot, since the inner
terms are contributing to this as well.